okay what am I excited about this
morning let's look at the job market we
go to fridays jobs report i know we've
got grease today those UK elections it
really looked like they could stretch
out could we have a second election
before christmas that's amazing we'll
talk about that all across bloomberg
surveillance today but let's look at one
surprising part of the American labor
economy let's look at fossils well why
would I want to look at that wait I'm a
fossil let's look at fossils people over
age 55 this is the unemployment rate I
happen to pick men here here's the trend
back to World War two and it's
wonderfully cyclical I mean this is this
is a gorgeous time series and yeah
you've got these three lower highs here
of unemployment among men over 55 and
then something changes this is amazing
this is a WoW statistic that's part of
that man session that we saw kick in
with a vengeance in 2007-2008 and the
headline that we see is what a comeback
here's a regular unemployment rate right
now we're men over 55 are down here
they've actually done better and there's
an old jumble of reasons for that maybe
they're taking less income maybe they're
taking less benefits maybe they have the
experience people want that would not be
in my case but anyways the fossils are
doing pretty good coming in here versus
where we are now with a regular
unemployment rate at five point five
percent but I just I never looked at
this chart before and what I'm excited
about is it's wonderfully cyclical going
back in nineteen sixty-five and then wow
what a change we saw in 07 08 so that's
my fossil chart for the day fossils over
55